[Music]
since I became your
Chancellor we have grown considerably as
a
country it is time to show America and
the
world precisely what we are
worth Madam Chancellor Corporal Zuber
you're here because you are nobody you
are not anybody and that means I can
trust you yes
chief
you will never be in control of this
place ever again
um he's not dangerous is he everything's
fine the J can be more pleased and we
like it when she's pleased don't
we yeah we
do have some pride let me do my work and
be grateful okay okay sorry without her
nothing makes sense who do have a
wonderful way with halfs don't
you yeah I'd like to see her is she
expecting you I'm her husband is she
expecting you one expects their husband
to enter a
room when I became your Chancellor I did
so with a heavy
heart but just know you fill me with all
the love I'll ever
need and so I bless you all all and I
bless our love
[Music]
always